-♪ What am I saying? ♪
♪ What am I saying? ♪
-It is time for
"What Am I Saying?"
This is based on a game people
have been doing online.
It's so much fun.
We have to read a phrase that
looks like gibberish
and guess the real phrase
that it sounds like
with 20 seconds on the clock.
Alright? I will go first.
You'll totally get this quick.
Alright, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
My first one up.
Pete's au tragles.
Pete -- Pete's --
Pizza -- Pizza bagels?
[ Ding ]
Pizza bagels?
Well, that wasn't that
hard, right?
Pizza tragles?
That didn't really change.
Alright, it's up to you now.
That was easy.
-Okay.
Bray calaig.
Break an egg.
Break a leg. Break a leg.
[ Ding ]
-That's right -- break a leg.
Good, good, good.
-Whoo!
-Alright, here we go.
It's a tie.
Wheneed some po.
Whenny tempo. Whenny tempo?
Whenny thump oh.
When -- Whenny --
Whenny thumpoo.
Ooh. Whenny Thumpooh?
Winnie-the-Pooh!
[ Ding ]
Wayney trempo?
I didn't know what that was.
Alright.
-What?
How do you even pronounce that?
Crab in your gourd.
Cram -- Cranny your --
Cran yourd.
Crammy your?
Cram a your hoard.
Cram your --
-Oh, I think I know what it is!
I think you have one of these.
-Grammy Award!
[ Ding ]
-Alright, this is awesome.
-This game, to me, is --
-Okay, here we go. Alright.
It's -- it's gone to be --
It's gonna be me?
[ Ding ]
Wow.
-Okay.
-I got that a bit too fast.
-Yeah.
-Alright, your turn.
-What?
This is Vegas.
Hot a pins in Vegas.
-Yes, give her the ding
on that one.
Give her the ding!
Give her the ding on that one.
[ Ding ]
-What happens in Vegas.
Alright.
Joust tin beer --
Oh, Justin Bieber?
[ Ding ]
-That was a --
That was quick, man. Boom.
You got that
like it was nothing.
-Alright, here's one
last one for you.
Then we're going to go together.
-Alright.
Dust ruffle es threo.
Distruffle is real.
-This truffle's real? Es real?
-No, when I was in Vegas, I knew
that this truffle would be real.
-Oh, the stru--
-The struggle is real.
[ Ding ]
The struggle is real,
especially in Vegas.
-Alright,
this is for both of us.
-Alright.
-Who let the dog -- dogscout.
Who letta the dogscout.
Doscout.
Oh.
♪ Who let the dogscout? ♪
♪ Who, who, who, who? ♪
[ Ding ]
♪ Who let the dogs out? ♪
♪ Who, who, who? ♪
Latifah, I love you!
Mwah, mwah, mwah!
You are the greatest.
Hugs and kisses.
I can't wait to see you soon.
Tell everyone I love them.
-Hey, listen, I love you, world.
Take good care of yourself.
Watch Jimmy.
-No, we love you.
Alright, pal. I miss you.
-Miss you, too.